didn't think your mom and dad would
leave you with nothing though did you
jk rowling left us with so many
questions about harry potter's parents
but the truth is
out about lily and james potter and it
sure is shocking
delve into all the scenes about james
and lily in the books and the movies and
you'll still be left
thinking wait what fortunately jk
rowling herself has revealed fascinating
little-known secrets and when you dig
deep
you find truths you'd never expect a car
crash
a car crash kalillian james potter james
potter came from a wealthy wizard line
where lily evans was from an ordinary
muggle family
but what's the truth behind why the
potters were so rich what happened to
both of their families
get ready for some answers harry is a
blend of his mother
and his father when he looks into the
mirror of arised
he realizes his mum's eyes are bright
green just like his
look very like your father except the
eyes of course you have your mom off his
eyes yeah
lily lovely lily but his messy hair
makes him more closely resemble his dad
it's not all about looks though or the
quidditch skills harry inherited from
james you never told me your father was
a seeker too
i didn't know sirius black and remus
lupin both saw glimpses of james's
behavior in harry
and cerveris snape certainly drew
uncomplimentary comparisons between the
two
you're just like your father lazy
arrogant freak but as dumbledore points
out and deathly hollows although harry
is like his dad
in looks his deepest nature is much more
like his mother's
and that's pretty important given the
negative glimpses we get of james as a
teenager
we're going to get to the bottom of why
james was so cruel to snape at school
and why he turned things around to later
become head boy
the truth might just surprise you
we're going right back to james's
childhood in 2015
jk rowling gave fans a long history
lesson on the potter family
in a web entry on pottermore the author
explains that potter is not an uncommon
muggle name
and that's why they didn't make it onto
the so-called sacred 28.
harry potter
harry potter the person who created that
list of truly pureblood families
suspected the potters had come from what
he considered to be
tainted blood however the wizarding
potter family actually had
impressive beginnings dating back to the
12th century wizard
linfred of stinchcomb his magical
remedies became famous potions
like skelegro and pepper up potion and
earned him a heap of cash
linford's son married the granddaughter
of ignatus prayerviral
and she inherited his invisibility cloak
which harry inherited from his dad
centuries later i know what that is
that's an invisibility cloak
i'm invisible as the compiler of the
sacred 28 suspected the potters didn't
stay pure blood
through generations they married their
neighbors who are sometimes muggles
but things get really interesting when
we get to james's dad
fleemont potter he quadrupled the family
gold by creating magical sleek yeezy's
hair potion
which hermione uses to tame her tresses
for the u-ball of course
is that a minor no i absolutely don't
fleemont sold his company at a vast
profit which he then passed on to his
only child with wife eufamina
jk rowling also revealed a few facts
about james's parents and childhood
in a 2005 interview with the leaky
cauldron and mugglenet
she explained that they were older when
they had james so he was a very pampered
only child
considered an extra treasure that could
go some way to explaining james's
bullying behavior at hogwarts
if he could do no wrong in his parents
eyes rowling revealed that they
succumbed to a wizarding illness
we later learned more details about that
from rowling the couple lived long
enough to see james marry lily
but dragon pox meant they didn't survive
to meet their grandson harry
james's parents made a key decision
during their son's time at hogwarts that
had a huge impact on james's turnaround
from bully to head boy
stay tuned for all the deets on that as
we need to give lily some attention now
i was the only one to see her for what
she was
lily's childhood and family background
are far removed from james's
rather than being part of a wizarding
home lily was part of a muggle household
jk rowling revealed she grew up in a
fictional town called
cokeworth in the midlands as did snape
and her sister petunia
sure didn't like lilly's talent
you're free despite petunia's meanness
lily remains kind-hearted
even as a child lily understood that
people's attitudes could be complex
and come from a place of pain it makes
sense that petunia's cruelty stemmed
from envy
my mother and father were so proud
in deathly hallows we discovered that
petunia wrote to dumbledore
asking if she could attend hogwarts with
lily and she continues with that
judgmental attitude with harry
when i knew he would be the same just as
strange
just as abnormal harry and lily were
alike in more than just magical ways
she sacrificed herself for her son and
harry was willing to do the same for his
loved ones
it's very hard to find information about
what happened to lily's parents
but jk rowling did actually reveal their
fate during an interview with the leaky
cauldron
and mugglenet in 2005. she explained
that as a writer
it was more interesting plot-wise if
harry was completely alone
so she rather ruthlessly disposed of his
entire family apart from aunt petunia
lily's parents passed away due to normal
muggle circumstances
she said there was nothing serious or
sinister about their passing
although her relationship with her
sister became unbearable
lily found friendship with snape in
childhood and their friendship created a
lot of the tension between lily and
james at hogwarts we learn a lot about
lily and james's days at hogwarts
during snape's worst memory in the order
of the phoenix like how lily described
james as an arrogant bullying toe rag
and she defended snape when james was
bullying him but snape was so
embarrassed by the whole
episode that he called lily a filthy
little mudblood
that put paid to their friendship and it
was snape's worst memory because lily
was
everything to him if you truly loved her
no one
and he could have been everything to
lily too according to jk rowling the
author revealed that in a 2007 web chat
on the bloomsbury site that lily might
have even grown to love snape
romantically
if he had not loved dark magic so much
and been drawn to such loathsome people
and acts
you've been a good and faithful servant
severus
but only i can live
forever in the deathly hallows we
learned how lily stood up to snape about
his creepy friends
she told him it was too late for their
friendship because of those precious
little death eater friends he hung out
with
with snape out of the picture lily fell
for james in their seventh year they
were a couple and were head girl
and head boy but how and why did james
change from being that arrogant bullying
tow rag lily had described him as
there's a fascinating fan theory by
emmett asher parent that refutes the
idea that james simply changed his ways
because he wanted to win the girl
he actually changed because of the
responsibility he felt towards his best
friend
sirius we learned how sirius was so off
the rails in their fifth year at
hogwarts that he told snape to head into
the whomping willow to discover where
remus had been disappearing every month
sirius considered it a prank but it
could have actually
ended snape's life james realized that
fact and stopped snape before he got
hurt that shows that james had a moral
compass
when sirius ran away from his awful
death eater family before their sixth
year he took refuge with james and his
parents
the potters were kind and supportive and
james realized that he needed to offer
sirius that same kind of stability
and protection after all there was a
wizarding war raging and james knew
things were only going to get harder for
them all
so james stepped up to be the kind of
mature compassionate person sirius
needed and the kind of person remus
could rely on too
his love for his friends changed his
behavior and the bonus was that he
incidentally became the sort of man lily
could love
but why did their relationship then move
so fast
many fans question why lily and james
got married so quickly
and so young they wed shortly after they
graduated hogwarts so they were still in
their teens
for now please join me in welcoming the
lovely ladies
but let's not forget the first wizarding
war was taking place at that time
the couple joined the order of the
phoenix during this dangerous time
surely they all felt that their days
could be numbered that could also be why
they had harry so quickly into their
marriage
just into their 20s are you as exhausted
as we are after all of those intense
revelations about harry's parents
which secret truth surprised you the
most how do you feel about lily and
james now
be sure to tell us in the comments
section thanks for watching
[Music]